calculators computers and teachers throughout your
life have told you that you can't divide by zero
but I'm here to tell you that you can
it's true in the real numbers
division by zero isn't defined
but neither is taking square root of -1
and yet mathematicians found a way to do it
checking all the details might be a bit complex
but ultimately the idea is just
"throw in a number whose square is
-1 then follow the normal rules of
algebra to figure out what this
new number system looks like"
if you do this with the square root of -1
you end up with the familiar complex numbers
they might have some weird properties compared to
the reals but they're a perfectly
good system of numbers to work with
can't we just do the same thing
with division by zero? can't we
just throw in an inverse of
zero and see what happens?
given that you've been told your whole
life that you can't divide by zero
you might expect that for reasons
you don't fully understand
you can't just throw in an inverse of a number the
same way you can throw in a solution to x^2 = -1
nope that's not the problem
the process of throwing in
the inverse of a number or
set of numbers and seeing what
happens is called localization
and it's no more difficult to do
than throwing in square root of -1
suppose you started with the integers
there's no 1/2 in the
integers so let's throw it in
in order to be able to multiply numbers
as usual we would also need to throw in
all the multiples of 1/2 including negative ones
and multiplying 1/2 with itself means we also
need 1/4 and all the multiples of a fourth
and so on and so forth
we need to add in anything that's
an integer divided by a power of two
but then we're good to go
we end up with what are called
the dyadic or binary rationals
which is another weird but
perfectly valid number system
if we also threw in 1/3, 1/4, 1/5, 1/6,
inverses of every positive whole number
then we end up with all the
rational numbers--ratios of
integers where the denominator is not zero
this is a pretty standard way
to construct the rationals
so what about zero inverse?
well let's do it
let's start with the real numbers
throw in an inverse of zero and
just see what kind of number system pops out
just like 1/2 is the unique
number such that 2 * 1/2 is 1
our inverse of zero is going to be the unique
number such that 0 * the inverse of 0 is 1
so let's assume that's true then what?
pretty quickly we see this implies that
1 equals 0 because anything * 0 is 0
but wait--this is not a contradiction
of course in the real
numbers 0 is different than 1
but in the real numbers x^2
can never be negative either
and yet we're perfectly okay in the
complex numbers saying that i^2 is -1
just because we've discovered an unintuitive
property of this new number system
that doesn't make it wrong
let's just continue and see where it takes us
take any number "x" in this system and note that
x is 1 * x because 1 * anything is that thing
but because 1 = 0 this is also 0 * x which
of course is 0 because 0 * anything is 0
thus we've shown in our new number
system that every number equals 0
there's still no contradiction, no error in logic
we've just invented what's called the Zero Ring
where 0 is the only number
0 + 0 = 0,
0 - 0 = 0,
0 * 0 = 0,
0 / 0 = 0
and 1 is just another label for 0
feel free to check that this
number system satisfies all
the normal rules of algebra it really does
so it's not that you can't divide by zero
it's just that if you allow it then all
numbers are zero and you get what you deserve